i gotta show you guys what i think is
one of the funniest stories i've seen in
the economic collapse this is from the
salt lake tribune shipping container
apartments opening delayed by global
shortages developer says hilarious okay
okay this is the latest the cost of a
shipping container is skyrocketing the
cost of transporting is going way up
they tried to make low income housing
out of shipping containers and now they
can't open it
this is like a fire truck on fire isn't
it it's like the perfect definition of
irony i know we'll use shipping
containers to create large cheap you
know low-income housing and now that
shipping containers are spiking so they
can't even do that
this is the perfect economic collapse
store i saw this i couldn't i just wow
i've been doing some research on them
they're expensive to transport which is
why they're having why they're not the
best thing to do and they're also you
don't know if they're going to be dirty
or that they ship toxic
chemicals
there's no insulation when once you
insulate them and the inside they become
much smaller they're only like eight and
a half to nine and a half feet high
anyway six feet that was in salt lake
city where it gets pretty cold look at
this this is crazy
imagine living in that have you guys
have you guys seen ready player one the
pod yes how they live in the stacks yep
that's what it is that's exactly what it
is in the pod yeah they have
these are up in san francisco they have
them
um look look look i love the idea of
getting a shipping container for
yourself and like burying it and having
a little clubhouse or something bunker
or doing a tiny house but this is the
stacks this is what we've been like
this is 1984 when the guy lives in that
crappy little cute concrete cubicle
welcome to your dystopian nightmare
california you will own nothing and you
will be happy in california you can only
get single-use containers uh like one
shipment version containers but
everywhere else apparently you can have
like they can transport transport
transport animal blood you know
phosphorus you don't know what's going
to be in it we're going to be breathing
in so i would at this point recommend do
not at least go look into it but at
least seems a lot worse than i thought
it was
i was just watching ready player one the
other day
and then when i saw this i was like oh
man so like all the mobile homes are
like stacked you know and people live in
these really awful conditions
well this is what you're going to get i
got to be honest the these shipping
containers are probably better living
than new york bachelor apartments huh
have you seen how bad new york is
uh i've been there once and it was uh
well recently they've got apartments
that are like it's a closet yeah and
there's like there's no bathroom yeah
you should live in one of those it's the
same as san francisco then so for a
studio in san francisco was 3 500 bucks
a month to 4 000 a month to rent why
that is a good question uh especially
after you know before
how does someone afford to live there uh
they
they go broke they eat a lot of freaking
cup of soup making a hundred thousand
dollars a year and pooping in the street
i have no idea well they make a lot
there's a lot of money floating around
that town there was in 2019 best economy
i've ever seen wow uh the trump economy
uh in my lifetime i am the amount of
money that was going through calif uh
san francisco in particular with the big
tech they're all centered there patreons
there uh twitter's there
downtown
yeah and uh they
and you know houses are expensive
there's always been money rolling
through there and there's always a
million people
this is before prior to covet but there
was a million people a day that would
just travel into san francisco so the
population doubled
uh on every business day
and i i i've never been able to explain
like a normal house i don't know how a a
a gardener lives in san francisco and he
must have bought his house 30 years ago
maybe it's like 10 gardeners all sharing
one studio maybe and they all just like
sleep in bunk beds
it's like good amenities um nice weather
you probably know better than i do and
then you've got the mountains to the
north uh in the east you have like
what's the city you have those sausage
sausalitos up north but like then you
got like kind of suburbian beautiful
farmland to the east
you know you got the 101 the pch
so it's it's it's located a nice spot
and the temperature is incredible if
you're down low in the hills it's cooler
and then you go up and it gets really
warm like up above when the sun's
hitting you
yeah i i've never loved city living so
i've never really gotten my head right
why people would want to be that close
to people and i lived there for 18 years
uh and i you know i i know you've lived
in cities before i don't know what
attracted people to it originally it's
just it sounds like the worst thing in
the world and i always think san
francisco there is that for if you're in
your 20s and 30s i get it uh as a family
guy i don't
uh you you're not taking your kids
to the tenderloin in san francisco i
moved there in 2016 for a year paid
three thousand dollars a month for a one
bedroom and uh they were trying to sell
me mushrooms on the street when i would
walk around that was something
interesting um but other than that i
never left the house my car got broken
into the day i went down there to look
for apartments i had my backpack in my
back seat came out and the window was
shattered it was gone that was rough
strong start it's
it was terrible i think it's an illusion
i think a lot of people i mean like
there's parts of it that were beautiful
there was parts of it that were nice and
there were parts of it that were fun but
i think a lot of it is an illusion
people build this up new york is this
fabulous city san francisco not new york
new york smells like sour milk yeah it
does it's all based on pre-internet
living before before you could get any
everything shipped to you it will you
could only find like cool jewelry in the
in the jewelry district in manhattan now
you just order it online they make it
and send it to you from japan or
wherever malaysia
china china
everybody had to say it yep
uh i i think well and then the mom and
pop capitalism which i love is
dead
so you had a comic shop in san francisco
yep what was the whole process of
starting it and then selling it oh it
was god it was great this was uh back in
2003 when i bought it it was uh hey i
won i want to buy your comic store and
the guy said yeah and we signed one
piece of paper
and that was it and you can't do that
now um and the landlord was cool i i got
lucky he was an old guy he liked me and
he gave me he said a thousand bucks a
month and he only raised it 25 bucks in
10 years wow and he felt bad when he did
it you can't do that now once the errors
take over uh as time went on the city
got more intrusive to the point where
they did a point of sale purchase
tax through the food and health i don't
even know how they wanted to get into my
taxes then that they wanted to so i just
got rid of the point of sale purchase
i'm like i don't have it anymore so you
can't tax me and you because i was
having to submit it and it was a way for
them to look at and that's their way to
sneaking in and looking at your taxes
the city so they started doing more and
more intrusive stuff like that no more
parking bikes everywhere you can't you
can't drive anywhere uh public
transportation got more uh more
expensive
crime went up uh my place got broken
into a couple of times they couldn't get
in but it got broken into it was like
regular yeah when the front window's
broken front door's broken and it just
got worse and worse and worse over time
so it did start out nice so but you you
no longer have this comic shop no i sold
it i sold it uh back in 2013 i'm happy i
did my wife owned a business
in san francisco for a two bit well she
had two salons and that went to one for
15 years
and she did great she did fine but she
had the deal later on it was there's a
homeless guy sleeping in the in the
front door every day
uh and that you can't just scoop them up
and get rid of them you can't call the
cops they won't come and get them
anymore san francisco if it's uh this
was before the they changed the 900 you
can go and steal 900 with the stuff and
they won't prosecute they will not
prosecute you um 20 years before that if
they broke into your car they did
something that was even short of being
violent you just went online and you
filled out a form and they might come
wow my friend kelly cutler was working
with the homeless up there and said that
every morning at 4 00 a.m they'll bring
like a fire truck or some something down
the street and just fire hose the
homeless people and make it so that they
get off the street
are you serious no no i mean i've been
hitting the water cannons before at
protests that's pretty severe i doubt i
i don't know i let's let's look at the
resources to that in san francisco you
said i haven't seen that i mean you've
never seen that no i've never seen him
leave a street uh it would have to be
like obama coming through or something
like that that was back in the day but
they they are a constant force all the
time especially down on six and the
tenderloin which i brought up but it's
spread out because they gave them cash
for the longest time that san francisco
gave them cash that's how they that's
how they're fighting
drugs they give them clean needles and
uh cash money once a month yeah i'm
gonna get in touch with kelly and see if
i can get her evidence on this because
that's where i heard all about this from
and then i'll bring it on the show maybe
we talk about it next week it was when i
heard that that they would be hosing the
homeless because they couldn't get them
to move otherwise without yeah i forgot
what they uh what they did when this was
a long time ago but when uh obama would
go there quite often for a fundraiser
and every time he came in they just
bought him bus tickets
huh wow it's like that south park
episode you ever see it
where all the hummus people come to
south park so then they get a yes yep
and they get everybody all the homeless
people to go to to to venice
that's what they do didn't didn't
concert or something you don't know on
south park they'd sing the song they're
like in the city city of venice right
next to matt's house that was a funny
line i love that one because matt stone
yep
uh
they've been doing that for a long time
giving them bus tickets to get out of
here they stopped doing it in california
because they're like it's great it's
great here we get cash we get needles
why would we want to leave uh ever yeah
i i i worked um
i worked for a homeless shelter in
california and
people don't understand what causes it
they just don't get it and it's and it's
it's really really frustrating when you
have these bleeding heart types who are
just like why can't we just take like a
house and then put the homeless in it
and they do this thing where you'll see
like high level progressive like famous
progressives be like there are more
empty homes in america than homeless
people and i'm like
okay and those are that's a non-sequitur
the reason the homeless people are
homeless has nothing to do with an empty
house
it has everything to do with their with
with many of these individuals choosing
to be homeless a lot i hear a lot
they're like mental illness is the cause
of of homelessness it is it is a cause
but my experience the biggest cause that
i experienced was people saying i want
to be homeless
they they enjoy living outside
they don't have to worry about much
people are giving them food and money
fresh air
but it's it's not even that it's like
they don't care they're under a bridge
they don't care you will not be you
can't you go to them and say look there
are a lot of homeless people who are
definitely in in hard times who want to
get out of that right who want to find a
place to live
but my experience most of them were just
like i don't mind sleeping under a
bridge why should i get a job people
give me free food all the time so i go
to sleep wake up walk around get free
food go back to my bridge and go to
sleep
how do you solve for that i honestly
don't know
unless you can't right you can't there's
there's uh there's i mean you've seen it
but there's three types of homeless
people there is the one who wants to be
homeless there is the mentally ill and
then there's drugs
uh drugs is the vast majority and ever
since uh the opioid crisis it's double
triple quadrupled uh the amount of
deaths in san francisco uh eclipsed the
amount of uh they're they're i would say
this there are the legitimate trope of
homelessness that the left thinks
someone down on their luck hard times
loses their home that exists definitely
and there's a lot a lot of people like
that have met many people like that but
it was not the majority it was like one
in ten yeah if and that may be generous
one in ten most people that we
encountered would say something like get
away from me i'm not going anywhere near
your stupid shelter i want to be
homeless
yeah they wouldn't say it's specifically
like i want to be homeless they would be
like i don't have anything to do with
your garbage and if they ever did come
in they'd come in for like clean clothes
a shower and then leave right away
yeah they uh i don't know the exact
story on this but they during when
everything was locked down they gave uh
they let homeless people in to a hotel
or a couple hotels in san francisco
there was a death in two weeks there was
fires inside they were caught dealing
drugs within a week it was just a
complete s show
uh and uh they had to continue it
because they they couldn't like how bad
would that look if they stopped it but
they were there was cops there all the
time and the hotels like uh wishing they
hadn't done it but they i i i would love
to find a solution to homelessness but
that means
arresting homeless people that in in
northern california they announced that
they would intern homeless people if
they were deemed not
yeah they would take their their
paychecks or any money they had coming
in and seize it and then lock them up
that's the only like that's the simple
solution because i tell you this when
you go up to homeless people and say
here's a house and they go no what do
you do
are you going to drag them into the
house and lock them in because that's
that you're going to have to these
people don't understand these leftists
are naive they think everyone assumes
the world they think everyone thinks the
way they do they don't realize that
people believe different things they
think every conservative is a grifter
because how could you possibly believe
that say jesus is the son of god or
something like that i don't believe
therefore they don't either and they're
lying or they're crazy it's like yo you
are not the arbiter of truth and
morality you don't know what you're
talking about this is what makes it so
hard to actually solve these problems
the the arrogant
exactly and
judging the world by their own standards
all the time uh you're not going to save
everybody i mean you know what what's
that saying that the left sees the world
for what they want to see out of the
world and the right sees it for what it
is i don't know if it's a correct saying
i don't even know if i said that right
but well you made it up if you did yeah
there you go i mean there's the
you're not going to save everybody we
need it doesn't mean you don't try but
uh as far as the homeless problem is
because it's not something you can throw
money at it's like the drug war that was
ridiculous it's the same thing uh you're
gonna have to fight the problem at home
and you're not gonna there's there's
hobos there's there's a whole culture of
you know do you know what hobo means
do you know that hobo
vagrant bum
vagabond all different things vagabond
is the obvious one that's like a wander
a wanderer a traveler but i learned this
hobo is a person who is looking for odd
jobs and is just passing through it
means homeward bound
oh interesting so i know that when you'd
see the cartoon of the guy with the
stick with the thing in it it's because
he's going back i guess the idea was
people would go out looking for work and
then when they failed they would start
heading back taking odd jobs along the
way so they didn't have any place to
live they didn't have a job but they
were looking for some work hobo
and then bums i think were people who
are like around the town not working
vagrants were usually like unable or
unwilling to like it was like typically
a negative like layabout and then
vagabond was just somebody without any
direction just traveling around doing
whatever
interesting huh yeah i've been called
that a couple times
yeah that one's not really derogatory
that one's just like you're a wanderer
and again you can only get hurt if you
give
power to words thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you